this morning we're closer to seeing at
least part of a highly sensitive
affidavit explaining in detail why the
fbi wanted to search former president
trump's mar-a-lago home the federal
judge who signed the search warrant has
ordered the justice department to
propose a redacted document for public
release at the same time the trump
organization's former chief financial
officer has pleaded guilty in a new york
tax fraud case potentially making him a
witness in a future trial senior
investigative correspondent katherine
herridge is outside the justice
department catherine good morning
good morning vlad thursday's court
action in new york and florida could
have significant ramifications for the
former president who faces multiple
civil and criminal investigations
meantime the justice department has just
six days to propose what information
should be blacked out or redacted from
that affidavit the trump spokesman said
the entire record should be public
on thursday the federal judge who
approved the fbi search of former
president trump's mar-a-lago home almost
two weeks ago found the justice
department had not met the high
threshold for showing that the entire
affidavit should remain sealed but he
did order the immediate release of these
other procedural records that provided
some insight into the possible crimes
that led to the mar-a-lago search they
include willful retention of national
defense information concealment or
removal of government records and
obstruction of a federal investigation
we are entitled to monitor the affairs
of our government at all levels the
judge agreed with media organizations
including cbs news that at least some of
the affidavit that supports the
mar-a-lago search could be unsealed it
is up to the public to determine what is
meaningful in this investigation
prosecutors argued releasing any portion
of the affidavit would threaten their
investigation and the safety of
potential witnesses and the fbi agents
involved doj is saying
there's a lot more to come scott
fredrickson is a former federal
prosecutor how extraordinary is this
situation it's surprising that the judge
is willing to
unseal any part of the affidavit the
government wins these arguments 99 out
of 100 times and whether it's president
trump or anybody else who's the target
of this search warrant that's very bad
news meanwhile in a state court in new
york city the trump organization's
former chief financial officer alan
weiselberg pleaded guilty admitting to
conspiring with the former president's
company to evade taxes on nearly two
million dollars worth of corporate perks
alan how'd it go in there
in the plea deal weisselberg agreed to
jail time and agreed to testify against
the trump organization but not the
former president himself when the case
is scheduled to go to trial this fall
tony
all right got it katherine herrich for
us catherine thank you very much